[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce débat des élections
municipales et communautaires 2020
consacré cette fois à la ville de morne
rouge et que j'ai l'honneur d'animer
avec alain livory alors trois candidats
têtes de liste sont présents dans ce
studio nous vous les présentons tout de
suite succinctement avant d'entrer dans
le vif du sujet et du débat et nous
commençons par jenny dulys petit âgé de
67 ans enseignante retraitée conseillère
générale de 1993 à 2010 vice présidente
du conseil régional de l'ex conseil
régional 2010 entre 2010 et 2015
actuellement conseillère territoriale et
membre fondatrice du mouvement aux ont
osé très bien alors je n'utilise je
poursuis que vous êtes maître maire
depuis 2008 et première adjointe depuis
vous avez été une première adjointe
depuis 1983 je ne me trompe pas c'est ça
il vous est peut-être de liste mme
rousse toujours deux gouttes alors il ya
aussi jean joseph malidor 63 ans
chirurgien dentiste vous allez mener la
liste union pour le réveil 1 co 6
municipal d'opposition vous situer à
gauche et vous étiez aussi candidat en
fabien bouquin fabien bouquin 58e dans
chaque chef d'entreprise
vous allez mener la liste tous ensemble
pour le monde rouge vous êtes aussi de
sensibilité de gauche
vous étiez d'ailleurs l'ancien colistier
de jean joseph malidor et vous avez
milité aussi avec monsieur m'a dit qu'on
lui même ancien candidat en 2014
c'est exact voilà donc pour la
présentation de nos trois candidats
invités à débattre et d'ailleurs on vous
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et maintenant avec vous alain
donc une courte présentation de la
commune du jour alors le mans ne rouge
s'étend sur trois mille sept cent
soixante quatre hectares la commune au
1er janvier 2020 comptait 5114 habitants
que l'on nomme les pelles et un en
référence à la montagne pelée et non les
rubis mornet en référence au nom de la
commune comme partout ailleurs le morne
rouge a aussi été meurtri par la seconde
éruption du volcan de l'appeler le 30
août
quelques semaines après la catastrophe
du 8 mai qui a anéanti saint-pierre et
prêcheurs le morne rouge perd environ
le 30 août 2009 102 perd environ 800
habitants sur les 1000 qu'elle compte le
30 août c'est d'ailleurs le jour de la
fête patronale du morne-rouge la commune
est aussi très connu pour le pèlerinage
de notre dame de la délivrande son
église voilà on a planté le décor pour
le morne rouge
le tirage au sort a désigné jenny dulys
petit pour répondre à la première
question elle vous sera posée dans
quelques minutes après avoir donc
écouter ces quelques habitantes et
habitants du morne-rouge que maurizio
l'temps a rencontré aujourd'hui c'est
notre traditionnel un micro-trottoir
commune agricole comme nous que nous
cache soutenu la production maraîchère
vivrières c'est en communiquant nourrit
la martinique alors mac a dit que
forment développer l'agriculture
correctement pour les jeunes j'ai
demandé plus d'offres aurel même si
c'est peut-être pas pour jeunes mais
animé la commune de temps en temps parce
que c'est rare de voir des choses ont
mon âge plus
puis ce développement de communes pour
la jsk arriver parce que c'est la
jeunesse qui est pourtant nous qui
vivons doit se situer la cad re diallo
limoux no cars go dit et c'est la
jeunesse qui pour limiter à l'aube est
tout ce qu'il ya de positif pour la
jeunesse tout ce qu'il ya de positif
pour l'environnement aussi séduit
sportif naturel et puis voilà
environnementale radio d'après ce que je
vois sur l'infrastructure montrouge il
ya plein de choses qui méritent de faire
d'eux de reprendre
au niveau les supermarchés au niveau des
petites boutiques dans le centre
revivre un petit peu de ce qu'ils
étaient avant parce que maintenant il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont laissés en
en délabrement et puis on a l'impression
que la commune se met on peut quoi
ce passons donc aux réactions à ce micro
trottoir madame jenny dulys petit quelle
est votre version
d'abord je tiens à vous dis merci de
m'avoir invité
puisque nous sommes encore grimper à
toute la population dense et nicaise
mais en particulier les payer leur
souhaitait beaucoup de solidarité bon
j'ai entendu ce micro trottoir que vous
avez eu ce matin vous dites mon nez
rouge avec je ne dirais pas que c'est un
micro-trottoir diriger mais enfin j'ai
entendu les oies il n'est pas bon il
n'est pas exhaustif c'est ce qu'on peut
dire c'est à dire ceci pollet sinon ça
voilà ça n'a pas valeur de sondage d'un
échantillon de personnes rencontrées au
hasard par notre journaliste et les
interrogent d'accord voilà très bien
j'ai pris nord se donne son site ici
comme contre 3 bien sûr quand on peut
jamais donner satisfaction à tout le
monde
vous avez toujours des pots et vous avez
toujours des contres s'agissant de
l'agriculture
nous faisons le maximum dans ce domaine
en tout cas dans le désenclavement des
terres agricoles nous sommes très bien
placés
nous faisons un maximum nous
accompagnons si nos agricultures par le
biais de rencontres avec au niveau
formation et cetera nous mettons tout en
place
programme d'animations c'est vrai que
nous avons les animations mais ne veut
pas avoir des animations toute une vie
il ya des choses qui se passent dans
l'animation peut-être que les jeunes
voudraient davantage de rencontres avec
eux des roms des artistes mais il faut
savoir que tout un coup dans la vie donc
nous faisons un choix et nous savons que
bon nombre de piliers sont satisfaits
des choix que nous leur donnons et
s'agissant bien sûr du développement
économique j'ai entendu parler des
petites boutiques qui sont morts c'est
vrai que comme j'étais jeune il y avait
des suisses appelés des boutiques mais
les choses évoluent et lorsqu'il était
il s'est agi de mettre en place le
carrefour il s'appelait champions à
l'est pas c'est vrai que nous avons
j'étais pas venir mais nous avons
rencontré tous les petits commerçants
nous leur avons même proposé à l'époque
de se rapprocher de cette grande
structure pour mutualiser les commandes
etc
donc il ya des choses qui se sont fait
peut-être que les jours les gens ne
voient pas et dans leur domaine sportif
aussi oui nous avons des infrastructures
que nous entretenons et des
infrastructures qui sont utilisés par
les sportifs qui sont en grand
nombre alors monsieur monsieur mugabé
soir dieter bohlen donc pour réagir à ce
mic au total donc ça va faire exactement
la situation de la commune donc je
l'avais répété une fois bon madame petit
me disais que je pars à 5 et aux jantes
à 20h la savoie fait exactement la
situation
donc nous avons une gare routière qui
est fermé nous avons la maison des
jeunes et la culture qui fermait la
place des fêtes le stap le terrible
tennis le truc à nous et le marché de
l'eau en gros il ya lieu de faire pour
le développement du mont rouge qu'est ce
que vous êtes en train de dire que tout
est fermé où on nous donne tout est
fermé donc radio qu'en gros à 18 heures
il ya plusieurs dans le monde donc c'est
à dire que tout était concentré sur le
goût et aujourd'hui ce que moi je
demande à madame d'ulysse de nous
expliquer pourquoi cette situation a
perdu et donc puisque l aime beaucoup le
mot loges
elles attendent elle aime beaucoup le
mono donc pourquoi cette situation
perdure donc si ça que je moi je pose à
qui jean joseph malidor oui mais votre
merci de me gêner réactions et
commentaires quand monde pour une bonne
année pour 7 pour la martinique et bien
sûr parce qu'on peut les payer
en fait ce micro ou trois ans nous
montre deux choses la première qu'il ya
une réalité est que monsieur moquin
viens de décrire et je le palais à
l'encontre de ce qu'il dit et puis de
l'autre côté l'autisme de madame
d'ulysse qui manifestement est sourde
aux demandes des indes nous avons
entendu des jeunes qui crient leur
désespoir et nous venons d'entendre
madame police qui dit que tout va bien
donc là encore nous sommes manifestement
dans un cas d'autisme et choix qu'il
faut qu'on en sorte
madame d'ulysse à 18 heures il n'y a
plus rien dans la vie la ville se meurt
dans le rouge ville morte à après 18h
ses inventions qu'elle n'avait jamais
été une commune où il ya des animations
toute la nuit
il faut le savoir si cette façon j'adore
ça peut changer les choses ne changent
pas du jour au lendemain
jallet
l'heure et je le répète il n'ya pas que
des animations maintenant j'ai été
attaqué sur la place des fêtes la place
des fêtes c'est pas tous les jours qu'on
fait de manifestation sur la place des
fêtes la maison le cliché la maison de
la culture il ya des animations espace
peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui sont
atteints de cécité et qui ne voient pas
après ce sont autant d'outils stade est
fermé
si la salle n'est pas ouvert tout le
monde savait que le stade avait le gros
problème sous l'ère de jus et vous
connaissez la pluviométrie
nous avons entamé des travaux il fallait
enlever tout ce qu'ils avaient le gazon
qui n'est pas bon et m
malade avec de mauvaises heures il
fallait enlever la terre également et
ensuite il fallait mettre de la bonne
terre est planté mais avec la
pluviométrie vous savez que ça n'avance
pas du jour au lendemain il faut donner
du temps au temps
et puis bien sûr nous avons demandé
beaucoup d'infrastructures sportives
mais c'est pas le meilleur qui va aller
pour le bal au football et je salue et
je remercie toutes les personnes du club
chilien qui utilisent en permanence à la
fois la salle de sport à la fois la
piste d'athlétisme et puis le stade de
saint lô le monde aux riches de la
commune dortoir
certains le disent mais malheureusement
je ne sommes pas que leurs droits
puisqu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de lieux où
on peut dormir vous avez le belge a
interpellé vous avez quelques gîtes mais
est justement fait non mais pour les
habitants les invitant à dire qu'on va
se voit la cesci vos concurrents ont
l'air de dire c'est que vous n'avez pas
créé ou n'avaient pas impulsé peut-être
suffisamment pour qu'il y ait des choses
qui se maintient la nation animation
forcément on attendait des animations
pas forcément des à chaque fois des
podiums
il est saine mais des activités
nouvelles et de loisirs de l'agriculture
la pose la question on pose la question
quand les gens viennent quand on les
fait parfois vous faites quelque chose
et puis personne ne vient pas ça des
élus sont invités viennent pas si on
soit j'ai envie de manger au mont rouge
quand je fais mes vous appelez à
l'avance dans la journée vous appelez ça
vous a priori jamais tapé les applis
restaurant le soir de la cité
ben aziza la demande aux voix à la
demande
oui alors ne dites pas le reste on ne
travaille pas le soir comprenez ce que
je vous dis nous ils ont hâte de voir
s'ouvrir par le soir c'est parce que le
propriétaire
je me suis alors encore une question et
puis vous vos concurrents réagiront à ce
que vous nous dire mais est ce que vous
estimez que il n'ya plus rien à faire
pour rendre le morne rouge plus
attractif mais à les animations qui sont
en fait nous avons une salle qui
s'appelle bâle a écopé dans laquelle il
se passe des animations pendant les
vacances y avait beaucoup d'animation
mais à des gens qui viennent et puis à
des gens qui ne veulent pas venir
donc ça suffisamment l'attractivité les
activités c'est vrai chaque année je ne
vous demande ces grands podiums et les
grands podiums d'animer des corps un
très très grand produit en le fait mais
on n'avait pas les moyens non plus mais
on était en face à des budgets et enfin
du financement on a obtenu ailleurs
joseph malidor pas écoutez moi je pense
qu'une utilité qui s'avèrent incapables
de résoudre les problèmes que suscite le
fonctionnement de la collectivité est
une édilité décadente aux preuves
il n'y aucune animation alors il s'agit
pas de construire de dire qu'on est très
fort en construction en bâtiment quand
on est incapable de faire fonctionner
ces bâtiments
quand on est incapable de les entretenir
c'est comme si on achetait en fait une
mercedes et puis prenez pas les moyens
de l'entretenir
mais le monde c'est exactement ça ça y
est on se glorifie pour dire qu'on est
les meilleurs
en réalité on a été les meilleurs on
était c'est vrai il ya quelques temps en
tête du peloton
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la fin du
peloton et il est nécessaire ça me rend
triste de voir comment il ya une grande
décadence ou montrouge comment le monde
rouge se meurt et comment cette jeunesse
elle n'est pas entendue
et c'est ça qui est terrible c'est à
dire que je reviens toujours sur cet
élément
c'est l'autisme qui liait au niveau de
la municipalité
mais je crois qu'au delà de tout ça il
ya une vraie volonté de se servir du
monde rouge effectivement on dit qu'on
est les plus forts les plus beaux on dit
qu'on a une une avenue on traverse le
monde rouge
effectivement tout ça ce sont des
éléments qui
conduit en fait à faire
le culte du moi le culte de l'ego et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ça qui donne
des ailes à certaines pour pouvoir quoi
qu'elles peuvent être éligibles aux
législatives mais tout ça on ne pense
qu'à soi on ne passe pas au moment où au
plus grand nombre
vous possédez la même chose vous avez
vous partager cette analyse monsieur
montcalm d'adieu au niveau du
morne-rouge c'est à dire que l'animation
qu'on demande c'est simplement donner à
tout à chacun la chance de s'exprimer ça
dure les associations parce qu on a pas
mal d'associations non on a quasiment
273 associations sur le monoï et il ya
une minorité qui fonctionne tout le
reste est laissé pour contre l'occ
sérieux trou créé cette animation il
faut appliquer les paie les dents et
l'actionnaire le maire sortant n'a pas
l'air d'accord y'a pas de 273 6 non nous
allons poursuivre et achever coeur
poursuivre et monsieur mouche non mais
c'est normal parce que si c'est que cela
que je relève la pause et à l'aula du
disant combien d'associations exactement
qui a ou bien que le quel est le nom de
l'agriculture est installée au boulot
c'est à dire que nous sommes laissés
pour compte au monoï nous sommes laissés
pour compte à dire on peut pas
s'exprimer on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
dire - mais voilà un jeune poids et le
jeûne sacré a besoin c'est d'activité ça
a dû lui donner la possibilité d'avoir
une activité donc c'est à dire que en
mettant pour vous disais et la
restauration pour l'image 1 pour les
fruits de montlouis nous il faut qu'on
descende au carbet au moment où nous
sommes basés que sur la pizza est là il
faut être clair
1 il faut pas se voiler la face on mange
une pizza ses homologues mais là pour
moi pour le fruité ou bien dès lundi il
faut des sonos kbc l'attractivité qu'on
veut rechercher mon âge la possibilité
aux jeunes de s'exprimer de développer
c'est ce que moi je donne un nom mono et
vous pensez qu'il ya pas les conditions
pour ça c'est à dire que il ya aubry ils
font briller il ya les infrastructures
les intentions des hommes
les infrastructures sont là c'est
simplement c'est une volonté politique
dit rien mais pourquoi donc quel serait
l'intérêt de cette équipe à madame
higueras mairie pour demander une
autorisation d'ouvrir
sadio de faire fonctionner son
association systématiquement si répondu
non il faut pas dire n'importe quoi mais
je suis très bien placé pour le dire a
marseille c'est à dire que les à chaque
fois comme ça c'est on nous a refusé
on veut faire si mais si vous refusez
vous savez pas pourquoi on ne sait pas
pourquoi puisqu'il n'y a pas d'élément
n'y a pas d'élément de reconstruire sa
doxa yeux quand vous consultez les et
dignité
il ya pas de réponse au tout et ça il
faudrait un touriste a quand même pas de
réduire ces soignants ou pas de répondre
à l' génie du dispostif vous et demandez
pas madame petit le plaisir de dire le
plaisir de dire non on ne parle plus
alors joseph peut-être sur les
associations
est ce que c'est ce que les associations
sont suffisamment soutenu aidé
accompagné alors manifestement il y a
les installations elles ne sont pas
soutenues et pourquoi tout simplement
parce que madame d'ulysse une se
gargarise de la proximité
sa grande proximité avec la population
alors ça peut paraître un avantage mais
je pense que ça peut être aussi un gros
inconvénient
parce que la proximité conduit à du
copinage et le copinage
ben ça empêche d'être clair et je peux
comprendre que ce soit difficile de dire
à ses amis à cette ati à ses cousins à
ses cousines à ses proches
non et sacré en fait une certaine
injustice et dans ce cas là le morne
rouge et un peu divisée d'un côté il ya
les proches donnent un petit à qui tout
est permis et pouvant elles mêmes
jusqu'à des indélicatesses et je veux
pour preuve certaines actions qui se
passe au sein même de sa collectivité
et puis d'autres fois qu'ils sont
frustrés alors qu'ils ont doit et qui
n'ont pas ce qu'ils offrent à vous
faites allusion à un certain nombre de
choses on peut avoir un exemple parce
que là c'est quand même l'avouer une
accusation quand même assez forte et moi
quand je dis quelque chose je maintiens
et je dis tout simplement que nous avons
eu dernièrement quelques mots dans le
cadre du conseil municipal où nous avons
un agent municipal qui demandait
les subventions à des entreprises et qui
demandait à ses en guise de liberté sur
son propre route et cela au su et au vu
de la municipalité à la limite tout
répondent et ensuite nous accuse
clairement de clientélisme et de
favoritisme l'association se créa
trentaine d'associations et toutes les
associations sont logés à la même
enseigne
ce que je veux dire c'est que il y a les
associations qui reçoivent une
subvention particulièrement le club paye
et le cope né un certain nombre de
sportifs aussi jeune que adultes
également le comité des oeuvres sociales
il s'occupe du personnel donc s'agissant
le copinage
je pense que il faut savoir le second
dit faut savoir ce que vous dites
il n'y a pas de copinage au monoï tout
le monde est logé à la même enseigne
quelques fait une demande pour
l'occupation je dois vous donne un
exemple d'une des salles en bas du
millénium
si cette personne la salle est libre
mais la personne obtient cette salle une
personne veut louer le millier d'hommes
c'est pareil mais on veut faire rentrer
tout le temps la famille de madame
d'ulysse et au millennium ce n'est les
bottes que vous maîtrisiez favoritisme
et moi même quand je veux faire une
manifestation je vais ouvrir le
restaurant de la place j'évite
d'utiliser ne serait ce que pour ma
famille toutes les manières il a été
accusé d'avoir favorisé je viens
d'entendre le mas my door une
association je lui ai donné la réponse
le conseil municipal s'est réuni samedi
dernier
en tout cas ils accusent de certaines
choses de vous les manières celui qui
accuse il a la charge de la preuve
donc je n'ai plus rien à ajouter celles
de mai mais vous vous niez ce qui ce
qu'il a avancé concernant un agent
municipal qui demande à ce que ce soit
versé sur son compte mais moi je n'ai
jamais donné de subvention avec votre
avec mon assentiment cela veut dire que
je fais partie d'une seule association
et cela depuis plus de 55 ans et c'est
de la seule et unique association à
laquelle j'apporte vous avez des preuves
de ce que vous avancez alors écouté
puisque l'occasion m'est donnée mais je
crois que le ici n'était pas là pour
débattre des affaires internes du
bandeau rouge mais beaucoup plus de
parler le projet mais puisqu'on va y
passer dans 5 minutes mais puisqu'en
fait
on me pousse à sortir des preuves
elles sont juste devant vous puisque
j'ai devant moi une en tête avec le
service des sports à l'occasion je
profite de dire que les services
municipaux doivent être créées par le
conseil municipal ce qui n'a jamais été
fait non qu'il n'y a pas de service des
sports effectivement mais il ya une en
tête avec le service des sports
j'ai aussi la photo de madame du lit ce
qui fait une grande lettre une grande
lettre aux chefs d'entreprise pour
demander la voyez là un courrier oui
avec là je tourne la page et je vois un
comité d'organisation avec la présidente
de l'organisation qui est madame
d'ulysse et je tairai le nom du
directeur de course qui lui fait des
indélicatesses
et puis je vous dirais tout simplement
une courte phrase tout versement cheikh
où un gouvernement doit se faire à
l'ordre de l'association que je tirais
responsable de la coordination de la
manifestation et c'est cela ne voulait
pas la phrase de son contexte parce que
le contexte je ne rêve pas là je trouve
que ce dossier mais je profite pour dire
que cette association dont madame du
lycée présidente elle s'est fait voter
une subvention au conseil municipal que
j'ai fait d'ailleurs dès le conseil
municipal précédent suivant faire
annuler tout simplement parce que il y
avait manifestement une illégalité une
prise une prise illégale d'intérêts
voilà comment fonctionne madame d'ulysse
ni vu ni connu je n'aurais pas dit ça
les choses continuent mais le monde ont
mis ces jo comme ça et je vous donne un
autre exemple savez que samedi avait une
manifestation au millénium qui ne
rapporte que 4700 euros par an un jour
rappelle cette manifestation est annulée
tout simplement parce que le millennium
n'a pas reçu l'accord de la commission
sécurité et cela depuis 2015
sauf que la veille madame de l'iss a
fait une grande réception qui a coûté en
gros 12000 euros ou 13000 euros
à la commune ou aider pour recevoir le
personnel et n'a jamais invité
l'opposition au portant sur le canal
info je vous assure madame que je n'ai
jamais reçu l'invitation mais c'est pas
grave situation vous veniez le bien
conseil municipal vous venez de dire que
c'est à celui qui accuse de porter la
preuve
non mais nous avons été mutés vous avez
été invité et la direccte et général
pour témoin pouvait porter les
convocations du conseil municipal en
même temps vous avez visibilité sur
votre père socialement ça a été fait
alors vous voulez dire que le personnel
ne fait pas son travail qui ne pouvait
jeter palissage et du conseil de
sécurité
oui nous avons que c'est pas du tout
nous avons aussi choisi de fermer les
yeux baissés mais à ces problèmes les
plus cruciaux est une utilité at il dit
ce qu'il veut et en plus il ment à la
population un mois avant l'élection qui
était réapparu six ans on vous voit pas
brusquement
vous oubliez apparaissez vous êtes
invité à toutes les manifestations
aussi bien la majorité qu'à l'opposition
moi je siège ailleurs de jésus et
religieux en plus les yeux dans les yeux
si les médias je ne viens pas conseil ce
ciment je vous met suffisamment dans les
conseils municipaux pour pouvoir dire ce
jeune super mal à l'aise mais vous ne
venez pas aux manifestations que vous
inviter pour le bus vous avez invité
l'opposition et d'altérité monsieur mali
de l'idée qu'il apparaît cette
invitation il a reçu vous l'avez du sud
chez massey malidor mais c'est de dire
qu'ils ne reçoivent alors il a été
adopté grave
il a dit qu'il vous a évité non prise
illégale d'intérêts et quand il jugea
vous dit qu'il a la charge de la preuve
je n'ai pas été président de la
manifestation est d'ailleurs lorsque
marie dont il faut dire la vérité aux
gens lors cela vous avez dit et redit le
président de l'association je ne suis
pas président de l'association j'avais
déjà prêté à une seule associé à lorsque
monsieur mali dans a interpellé au
conseil municipal
nous avons pris bonne note et nous avons
à ce que j'ai dit c'est mieux si pas
leurs noms mais je vous ai pas dit quand
vous ne venez pas aux français de se
voir prêter quand vous n'êtes pas dans
la population
et quand vous ne répondez pas
dernièrement il faut savoir aussi ce que
monsieur mario nous avons un conseil
municipal monsieur malidor a voté contre
le personnel
il vous dit pas ça non plus
il a également dit que ses patronymes
japon il s'agit du comité d'organisation
avait tout à fait ils vont de
l'organisation l'année le maire et elle
demande une subvention pour ça mais
chacun sait qu'il présente sa déception
suite mais je suis n'y a pas ici il n'y
a pas eu de certains venus lorsqu'on est
conseiller municipal pour leur soirée la
majorité ou de l'opposition lorsque
quelque chose ne va pas on étire funk et
ça permet de remettre en ordre les
choses qu'est ce que cela vous inspire
tout ce que vous entendez me suis donc
et bien ça m'inspire le changement c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut il faut
changer le il faut changer le mode
évolue radio en avance je pense que
madame petit aujourd'hui un petit peu
dépassé
peut-être aussi ses mandats en trou et
je pense qu'il faut qu'elle le slam elle
est candidate là pour un troisième
mandat mais sauvé trois depuis 83 demain
à la librairie à une question précise à
vous poser facilement quand vous étiez
sur la liste de monsieur m'a dit d'or
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait liste
commune cette année
vous étiez en 2004 en 2014 pour ça pour
2020 comme cette liste commune ben tout
simplement c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé entre 2014 et maintenant coiro en
2014 effectivement bon monsieur mali
d'eau était tout le temps pour ces
municipales il faut l'avouer mais jamais
sur le terrain c'est à dire qu'on ne le
voyait pas sur le tir et je vous
confirmer ce que disait madame
il faut pas se voiler la face un mois je
dîne vérité aujourd'hui j'ai pris la
décision c'est pour cette raison que
j'ai pris cette décision de me présenter
aux élections depuis deux ans un an et
demi parce que il n'y avait pas je ne
voyais pas monsieur mali d'eau donc j'ai
pris la décision maintenant qu'il est
revenu
bon maintenant ça me met un petit peu en
porte-à-faux avec mes colistiers puisque
la plupart des colistiers que j'ai fait
venir avec moi et qui retourne et un
petit peu avec monsieur malino donc ça
me met en porte-à-faux ça veut dire que
vous ne pouvez pas faire de liste sans
aux journalistes allez faites
allez faites mais ça l'est tout cet
office est le plus difficile du plus
difficile que prévu imprévu ce qu'ils
ont tous à retourner avec le retour de
monsieur major alain problème explosé
jeudi aux camarades du doigt le même
problème parce que quasiment tous les
colistiers dans l'ancienne équipe a
laissé tomber ça dure on a on a eu le
dégoût de la politique comme on nomme
séduit une démobilisation des
sympathisants et c'est ce que moi
j'essaie de le faire et je vais lancer
un appel du pied avec pour eux qu'il
faut pas vous voulez vous présenter en
homme neuf en quelque sorte celui qui
apporte la nouvelle donne entre
l'opposition
déjà maintenant depuis plusieurs années
et puis là cet examen dames le maire qui
veut elle
donc nous sommes un troisième mandat
avec de nouveaux perspectives pour le
montage est ce que vous ne faites pas le
jus de mesdames d'ulysse pense qu'en
2014 gable aussi trois candidats mellon
du lys a été élu au premier tour
au début quand je me suis présenté
effectivement il y avait plus de
candidats doxa pouvait changer la donne
monsieur merli d'eau arrivent
effectivement et un doute mais je pense
que le mot rouge a besoin de changement
le peuple en général disent ils aux
changements vont maintenant on verra par
6 à ce quotidien est ce qu on va s qui
va changer qu'est ce qui va changer
qu'est ce que vous proposez de plus que
keane que vous n'aviez pas fait par an
en 2014 par exemple - cinq hommes
je veux instruits sur le savoir-vivre
montrouge donc le savoir vivre c'est
l'honnêteté le respect oui et on va
donner la démocratie au monde parce
qu'on a tendance à avec le système de
copinage
bon il faut qu'on arrête avec ça c'est
dur quand nous sommes dans un système
radio loutrons de nous nouvelle ère
politique parce que il faut qu'on arrête
tous ces petits cons quand le politique
à la tuerie
donc il faut qu'il y ait une vision
positive pour les jeunes
on a besoin c'est à dire qu'il faut il
faut il faut répondre à la population
concrètement maintenant il ya plus de
deux poches des familles nous bien il
faut du concret alors tout à l'heure
vous à les concrétiser peut-être une ou
deux propositions que vous faites à la
population du morne-rouge parce que
voilà il faudrait qu'on ait des choses
un peu plus concrète la salle des
exemples de propositions phares et
également aux autres juste comme ce sont
des élections municipales et
communautaires
jenny dulys petit on dit que vous avez
eu des relations difficiles
en tant que maire avec la communauté
d'agglomération du pays nord la cap nord
est ce que c'est vrai comment je vois
les choses
le problème c'est que la lampre s'est
installée et il ya c'est là qu'il ya eu
un petit peu le copinage au moment de
l'installation dans la communauté
il aurait fallu équilibré et met les
visées et les vice-présidents sont
fonction du nombre de communes et aussi
du lieu géographique et à le nom et à
localiser le nom atlantique mais
cependant je n'ai pas eu de difficultés
sérieuses à vous empêcher de travailler
avec eux j'ai tout donné grand sud et le
faux j'ai travaillé je suis à l'eau aux
réunions au conseil communautaire
et puis nous avons présenté aussi des
dossiers qui ont pour lesquelles nous
avons obtenu satisfaction donc nous
n'avons pas eu de blocage avec la
communauté d'agglo bien au contraire et
les relations se poursuivre vous
entendez quoi par copinage parce que
des coupes de copinage lors de
l'interview vous étiez la martinique
entière a vu comment les choses se sont
passées au moment de voter pour le
président il ne serait ce qu'au moment
de choisir les dix président je vous
donne un exemple je ne lui permet pas
une place de vice président pour jenny
dulys petit je disais pourquoi ne pas
faire jouer la parité et c'est à ce
moment il avait que j'avais choisi que
des hommes disant que la loi le précise
pas mais je disais antoine on pouvait le
faire mais là bon ils ne l'ont pas fait
après il ya eu une vice présidente parce
que quelqu'un était décédé bon elle a pu
obtenir tant mieux pour eux mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je n'ai pas fonctionné
je fonctionne avec tout le monde même
s'il faut que j'appelle pour quelque
chose un problème au niveau de la
commune j'ai un interlocuteur qui me
répond toujours favorablement et mes
dossiers sont bien en majesté et
accompagner le chaos après on a fait à
ce niveau alors vous nous direz tout à
l'heure ce que vous entendez proposer à
la population du monde pour cette
nouvelle mandature
jean-joseph malidor on passe un peu aux
propositions au projet puisque nous
approchons du terme de démission alors
que le rythme enjoué quand même réagir
vous savez bien qu'une commune comme la
nôtre qui est vraiment situé sur une
arête à 10 minutes de saint-pierre 30
minutes de fort de france venus de loin
à une un vrai potentiel agricole
mais à d'autres potentiels qui peuvent
être jeudi et d'autres potentiels qui
peuvent activer avec cap nord et il est
impensable que la municipalité du monde
rouge ne puisse pas avoir une bonne
entente avec le bailleur de fonds qui
est cap nord et ça c'est une erreur
fondamentale
la deuxième chose c'est que d'accord on
peut proposer des dossiers mais si nous
n'avons pas fait le travail en amont
ça veut dire avoir les déserts foncière
pour pouvoir le faire je pense à à
l'assainissement
aujourd'hui le monde en rouge est
assainie à moitié les réserves foncières
n'ont pas été faites
aujourd'hui les longs qui mériterait un
vrai programme et que le pnm sollicite
tous les jours sans compter que l'unesco
va arriver et dont ce serait une vraie
manne financière où nous nous sommes
incapables et d'ailleurs madame d'ulysse
bloque un peu le dossier je ne sais pas
pour quelle raison toujours est il que
nous sommes à l'arrêt sur ce dossier et
ça ce sont des éléments qui peuvent
faire en sorte que le moment où je
puisse décoller je ne nie pas que c'est
en faisant venir des gens
qui passe je veux dire tout simplement
qu'il ya une nécessité de rendre le
moment où jacques actifs et le monde
rouge attractif
c'est à travers d'abord la rigueur que
nous pouvons avoir dans l'administration
communale le copinage ne favorise pas
cela c'est aussi l'équité que nous
pouvons avoir
et là encore le copinage ne favorise pas
à ces éléments là et puis bien le bien
vivre au monde rouge c'est permettre aux
gens qui viennent montrouge d'avoir de
l'animation d'avoir des édits cap des
éducateurs pour garder leurs enfants de
faire en sorte que les salles de sport
un bel sont ouvertes et qu'elle soit
surtout entretenu et animer tout ça sont
des éléments qui forment que les gens
viendront mon autre il ya plus de 500
maisons au moins rouges qui sont des
habitués qui sont qui sont vides parce
que les gens qui partent et salomon où
il n'est pas attractif et donc moi je le
fais fort de faire en sorte que le maire
ne skient ce qu'il soit maire et que les
délégués communaux les délégués
communautaires soient des jeunes parce
que ce sont les jeunes qui doivent
permettre d'avoir un avenir
ils doivent travailler leur avenir bien
sûr favoriser leur présence le présent
aujourd'hui vivre le présent mais aussi
préparer l'avenir et c'est aux jeunes le
fait monsieur mouquin comment rendre le
monde ou aux jeux peu plus attractif
donc tout d'abord c'est au niveau de la
citoyenneté de clips et les au coeur de
l'action sanyo informer et dialoguer
impliqués dans la gestion de la commune
donc ça c'est important de communiquer
et il faut savoir que tout citoyen a des
doigts vis-à-vis de la mairie
on a fait plaisir excusez-moi vision il
faut savoir que tout citoyen a des
doigts vis-à-vis de l'amérique mais là
mais lui aussi a des doigts vis-à-vis du
citoyen oui donc
donc il ya la fin de programme et de
nature un peu d'engagement citoyen
dégagement citoyens sa durée mocratie
participatif c'est ce que vous mettez en
avant donc manifestement oui l'éducation
vous inscrivez dans ça voilà la vie de
coach c'est comme ça qu'on pourra
commencer à développer ensuite par
rapport aux comptes communaux on verra
les grandes mines sadio league il grands
projets par la suite mais pour le moment
ton sortir du mono ou de ce malaise
c'est comme ça qu'il va falloir et à
posséder alors jenny dulys petit donc
allons-y bain donnez-nous je vous
demande de me donner un ou deux exemples
de projets de plaisir que j'entends
parler de citoyenneté et démocratie
oui il faut bien sûr mais encore
faudrait-il que ces personnes là
viennent quand on organise des réunions
de quartier on y voit jamais tenons
régulièrement des réunions et nous
discutons également que le placement je
vais pas m'amuser à répondre à tout ce
qui a été dit simplement je veux parler
de des projets que nous avons pour cette
mandature puisque c'est une nouvelle
mandature nous avons prévu un
accompagnement particulier continuer
l'accompagnement aux créateurs qui
veulent développement dans le cadre du
développement économique nous allons
mettre en place aussi ce qui s'appelle
ne ment pas une maison de seniors pour
dessiner autonome c'est un projet
également la maison de france services
au public que nous allons également
installer nous avons nous sommes déjà en
pourparlers
nous allons continuer la mise aux normes
de bâtiments communaux comme nous
l'avons fait aujourd'hui être avec 15%
des bâtiments communaux à l'avis
favorable de mission sécurité
nous avons favorisé dans le domaine du
tourisme l'accueil chez l'habitant
parce que nous l'avons déjà fait avec
des associations continuer à accompagner
toutes les associations comme nous le
faisons répondons non seulement à leur
demande mais répondra également à leur
invitation
nous allons encore continuer la
population à désenclaver les routes
parce que nous avions commencé la venue
du 30 août pour permettre un dégagement
du bo dégager le beau mais permettent
aussi l'installation de parking
le bo est avec quatre noms nous avons le
projet justement de d'une piscine une
piscine chauffée et couverte sur le
monde et aux jeux mais avec cap nau
puisque cap non comme on le disait tout
à l'heure le meilleur de fond et nous
allons nous avons le projet d'avoir un
vrai service de police le service de
police mme vous avez bien sûr un musée
pour permettre leur coût bien connaître
l'histoire à la fois dans la commune et
l'histoire de la religion au tour de la
commune et puis je vous ai donné alors
des conventions avec les différents
organismes pour animer justement la
ville continue et l'animation comme nous
le faisions toujours voilà alors à
l'allégorie à une question mais qui
appelle une réponse très courte parce
qu'on revient aux conclusions là sur
l'agriculture avec les terres saines que
pensez vous de ce label 0 chlordécone
est ce que au morne-rouge vous avait
recensé dit eller déconner mais nous
avons recensé des terres avec le
collègue responsable juillet passionnant
de la commission agriculture certes il
ya des terrains chlordécone et tous nous
les avants mais les agriculteurs
travaillent sur des terres saines et non
seulement je voudrais aussi répondre
dans le domaine du foncier le monde
house et la communiquer le plus le
foncier ils vont vous dire que les
bailleurs ne viennent pas pour
construire
nous avons proposé nous aurons aller
loin très loin avec la préfecture et
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien frémissement
puisque ozanam viendra bientôt la cimade
également donc il y a des choses qui
sont patients même qu'un monsieur
mouquin sur le développement agricole
comment accompagner les agriculteurs
pour obtenir ce label
zéro chlordécone de quel type d'action
donc il faut les mobiliser sur leurs
parcelles sadio répertoriés mais pas
celle ci soit déconner au nom de la
famille lite et la traçabilité est comme
ça là on pourra les accompagner dans
leur les différentes cultures
mais il ya une chose qui n'est pas tout
aussi sur le mont rouge qu'on met jamais
en valeur c'est notre légumes le shoot
chine et ça qu'on met pas en valeur
n'ont pas suffisamment parce que c'est
notre produit duty world le shooting mon
âge et ça il faut qu'on le mette en
valeur et donc faut faire mieux encore
festive le festival n'est pas suffisant
a validé ses valises à l'agriculture à
mon avis c'est une chance que nous avons
peut-être d'avoir dicté accueillant
déconner ça va faire bondir tout le
monde mais l'état reconnu sa
responsabilité
pour nous il est nécessaire aujourd'hui
que l'état pense que ce concept et
jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire financier le
matériel et financer la formation
ça nous permettra d'avoir des petites
structures qui permettrait de développer
l'agriculture au sol or chlordécone
on parle d'une machine à mon avis il
faut aujourd'hui créer un label quand
vous faites de la chine à sainte-anne
s'est vendu sous le nom de la chine
morne-rouge donc il faut qu'on arrive à
créer un label de produits montagne avec
non seulement mon rouge avec toutes les
communes autour de la montagne qui
couine cause de lâcher mais j'ai
beaucoup d'autres propositions il
voudrait bien que nous n'avons pas le
temps pour ça voilà donc on en vient aux
conclusions la minute la minute de
conclusion vous adresser directement
donc qu aux auditrices et auditeurs aux
internautes et en particulier bien sûr
aux électrices et électeurs du du
morne-rouge eux allez-y madame eugénie
dudit ce petit bien population du mans
le rouge pellet ncp lien vous le savez
oui il a été rappelé que je suis en
politique depuis 1983 c'est vrai mais
vous me connaissez bien avant je vous
invite à ne pas vous laisser avoir par
ces personnes qui aujourd'hui vous font
de belles promesses et une fois que les
élections sont passées on ne les voit
plus ou le territoire je vous remercie
de la confiance toujours renouvelée
et je vous invite à faire le bon choix
aussi le 15 mars prochain
en choisissant jenny dulys petit dès le
premier tour pour continuer le travail
commencé et vous le savez tous que
madame du lis ici présente est à votre
service 24 heures sur 24 et 365 jours
sur 365 jours donc je suis à nouveau
candidate et je vous remercie de me
faire confiance pour ces élections du 15
mars 2009 c'est à vous maintenant
monsieur mon kart cross européenne donc
on demande des jeunes à s'impliquer dans
la politique
aujourd'hui je suis un jeune qui s'est
impliqué dans le mouvement de
développement sur le monoï
je vous demande de me faire confiance et
de faire confiance à cette jeune équipe
tout simplement nous le 15 mars dès le
premier taux votés fabié mon cas le
tirage au sort vous a dit ça les vaut
qu'on gagne l'émission est un leader si
c'est vrai qu'après après avoir entendu
les marchands de sable
je ne peux que conclure à chaque citoyen
chers amis ma candidature s'inscrit dans
la dynamique du changement que vous
souhaitez depuis longtemps je suis la
voix de vous tous qui souhaitaient une
vie faite d'équité de justice et de
solidarité
alors je suis la voix aussi de cette
jeunesse qui souhaite améliorer son
présent et préparer son avenir avec
fierté et détermination ne les décevons
pas une nouvelle froid c'est pour cela
que je vous invite à voter sans peur dès
le 15 mars la liste l'union pour le
réveil que les conduites par votre
serviteur
joseph m'a dit d'or merci à vous trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat
voilà une réalisation assurée par audry
calixte et puis prochain débat sur notre
antenne vendredi et puis il y en aura un
également sur l'antenne télévisée demain
[Musique]